It's official: Singer/actress Halle Bailey
is earning her fins as Ariel — and now,
following a bit of backlash on social media,
she's breaking her silence about being cast
in the upcoming remake of The Little Mermaid.
As you may already know, Bailey is a 19-year-old
singer who performs alongside her older sister
Chloe in the R&B duo Chloe x Halle.
"Hey guys, it's Chloe."
"And Halle."
She's also an actress on the hit show Grown-ish.
"You practice a little bit of it every day.
And you know, you can't get curl and life
goals in one weekend."
"Wow, you're right."
In early July, the House of Mouse announced
that she'd been cast as Ariel in the live-action
remake of The Little Mermaid, and the news
caused something of a stir on social media.
Some fans of the original expressed disappointment
over the casting choice, expressing that Bailey,
a black woman, wasn't the right person to
play Ariel, who is depicted as having white
skin and red hair in the 1989 animated original.
Now Bailey has come forward to reveal her
thoughts on the matter.
"Feel like I'm dreaming, and I'm just grateful,
and I don't pay attention to the negativity."
She added,
"I just feel like this role was something
bigger than me, and greater, and it's going
to be beautiful.
I'm just so excited to be a part of it."
In a separate Variety interview, Bailey admitted
that,
"[Taking on the role] is definitely a little
bit nerve-racking because I am the little
sister.
I am so used to [us] always going through
these challenging moments in our career together,
[but] I am beginning to understand that this
film is so much bigger than me.”
This is the first time Bailey has publicly
addressed the criticism… but in July, she
revealed that she's overjoyed about landing
the role.
"It's really, really exciting, you know?
I just feel really grateful right now.
I'm still really in shock.
I just found out a day or two ago."
Unfortunately, the backlash hasn't entirely
settled yet.
One fan even started an online petition, writing
that:
"We feel the casting is a betrayal of Ariel's
original creators, die-hard fans and small
children the world over who just want to see
the Ariel they already know and love brought
to life for the big screen."
Of course, plenty of people are praising the
casting choice — including Jodi Benson,
who voiced Ariel in the animated movie, its
sequels, and a number of television projects.
Benson defended Bailey's casting by saying:
"I think that the spirit of a character is
what really matters.
What you bring to the table in a character
as far as their heart, and their spirit, is
what really counts.
[…] No matter what we look like on the outside,
no matter our race, our nation, [or] the color
of our skin."
On July 6th, the Disney-owned cable network
Freeform published an open letter on Instagram
firmly standing by the casting choice.
The post read in part:
"The character of Ariel is a work of fiction.
So after all of this is said and done, and
you still cannot get past the idea that choosing
the incredible, sensational, highly-talented,
gorgeous Halle Bailey is anything other than
the INSPIRED casting that it is because she
'doesn't look like the cartoon one,' oh boy,
do I have some news for you… about you."
Director Rob Marshall also voiced his unwavering
faith in Bailey's talent, telling Variety:
"[She possesses a] rare combination of spirit,
heart, youth, innocence, and substance — plus
a glorious singing voice — all intrinsic
qualities necessary to play this iconic role."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.